PHIL QUITSLUND: Good morning.
So I'm Phil.
Jacob's over there.
He's going to come on
stage in a few minutes.
Welcome to DartConf day two.
Congrats.
This has been a real
pleasure so far,
and it's a real honor to be up
here to show you some new work
that we've been doing.
So Jacob and I are
going to introduce you
to the Flutter Widget
Inspector, a new tool
for the IntelliJ plugin that
helps you visualize, explore,
and debug Flutter UIs.
And if you were at
Tim's talk yesterday,
you may have remembered
him describing Dart
as being the engine,
Flutter as the fuel.
You can imagine a bit that what
we're going to show you today
is like a diagnostic tool
that will help you understand
the check engine light
in the unfortunate event
that it turns on
for your Flutter UI.
So as it turns out,
understanding the check engine
light in a Flutter
UI is a little bit
different than for
other UI frameworks.
We're going to start by talking
a little bit about that.
Then we're going
to give you some
of the basics of the
inspector, how it works.
We'll do a demo, which I
hope you'll find is awesome,
and will inspire you to
give it a whirl yourselves.
We'll wrap up with some
status and next steps.
So what makes an inspector
for Flutter different?
So the first thing that I
want to draw your attention to
has to do with the
Flutter framework, itself.
And if you look at this now
probably familiar picture
of the Flutter Stack,
the salient bit
here is how much is happening
up above the engine level.
So what you'll notice,
it's not so interesting
that it's layered as
much as how much is up
in those upper layers.
And you'll think from
the tooling perspective,
the bit at the bottom,
the engine part,
is fairly opaque to tooling.
And what that means is it makes
our job a little bit harder,
because it means that we
don't get to leverage a bunch
of native low level tools.
But it gives us the
distinct advantage
of being able to
give you a tool that
can describe quite
a lot of what's
going on in a uniform
and consistent way.
So the next bit
that I think bears
attention has to do with a
fundamental design decision
that the Flutter folks made.
And the salient thing
here and fundamental bit
about Flutter UIs is that
just about everything
that you can imagine has
been modeled as a widget.
So I'll go through
a few examples,
in case you haven't
internalized that.
So one example that
surprised me was
to find out that things like
themes are modeled as widgets.
Animations are also widgets.
Apps show up in the
widget tree as well.
Layout components,
and this turns out
to be very powerful, although
at times, surprising,
down to things much more
esoteric like like gesture
detection.
So this design makes for
some unique opportunities,
and introduces also
some challenges.
And in particular,
one of the challenges
that's really fundamental
to understanding Flutter UIs
is how deeply nested
these trees can become.
Moreover, the trees
are not only nested.
They tend to comingle concerns.
So you'll notice at the very
top and at the very bottom
of this tree snippet,
those are the widgets
that you, as a user,
have invested interest
in by defining them
in your build method.
But everything else is
coming along for the ride
from the framework.
So that's quite a lot to manage.
So what that suggests
is for a tool
to help you successfully
navigate UI in Flutter,
it's going to have to be
pretty good at moving you
between different
neighborhoods of widgets,
and also help you
distinguish where
your stuff ends and
the framework begins,
and hopefully get you
to move seamlessly
back and forth between them.
So another challenge,
although, I'd
say this is just as
much an opportunity,
is that widgets in
Flutter are defined
in source, in Dart
source, and not
in some kind of simpler
markup language.
So that presents some
implementation challenges
for us, because it means
that our tooling needs
to be very robust with respect
to understanding Dart source.
Now, the good news
is, we get to build
and we have built on a
rich, open-ended extensible
framework, which you've
learned quite a lot about,
I suspect, here already.
The analysis tooling
for Dart is great.
So that brings us
to what we made.
The Flutter Inspector s a tool
for visualizing Flutter widget
trees.
And the basic idea
is that it helps
manage bidirectional mapping
between an active Flutter
UI and the visualization of the
widget tree that corresponds
with it, and notably also
the render tree, which we'll
talk about in great detail.
So further than that, you
can follow this mapping
deeper into the source so that
you can see where in your code
or in the framework
code these widgets are
being created and configured.
And it turns out
that's very powerful,
and gives you a
lot of clues when
you're trying to understand
a big UI or debug your own.
So that's a lot of talking
without a lot of demoing.
So let's bring Jacob up.
And if we could switch
over to the demo machine.
And Jacob's password.
JACOB RICHMAN: All right.
So now you've seen my password,
so we're all set here.
So I've got IntelliJ running,
with the Flutter gallery
app running in iOS simulator.
All of this will work equally
well with the real device.
This is just a setup that's
easier for me to demo here.
And you'll notice currently, the
application's running normally.
But I'll show the very
first thing you always
want to do with the
Inspector, which
is to select the widget
you're interested in.
So I'll tile the Inspect Mode.
And now when I interact
with the device,
instead of interacting
with the app,
it's showing me what which is
responsible for that position
on the screen.
So you can go around and see
how this app is structured.
Let's go ahead and click
on a particular widget.
Now as soon as I do that, now
you see the tree of widgets
over on the right side here.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Great.
So for the purposes of
nudging this demo along,
I'm going to play
the role of a newbie.
While I have lots of experience
writing developer tools
for Flutter, I
don't, in my day job,
get to do a lot of
Flutter UI development.
So this isn't actually
that much of a stretch.
We're also going to
fold in a few episodes
from some of our observations of
folks that are new to Flutter.
And we're going to tackle
a couple of common puzzles.
So to start with, Jacob,
why don't we drill in?
And maybe you can make a
source modification to this.
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah.
So you'll notice a couple of the
widgets in this tree are bold.
And those are bold not
because of what kind of widget
they are, but because of
where they were created.
Those were widgets
created directly
in the gallery application
instead of the framework.
And now, you'll see if I select
one of those bold widgets,
immediately, my
source window jumps
to where I've created that
widget, right in the Flutter
gallery home page.
And so I'll go
over the text one.
And here, you can see there's
where the Flutter gallery
text is defined.
I didn't have to go searching
for the text and source
code or anything like that.
There it is.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Great.
So can you maybe update it--
[APPLAUSE]
JACOB RICHMAN: So
it's very exciting.
Amazing when this
works the first time.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Woo!
So while we're
here, why don't we
update it to something
a little more topical?
JACOB RICHMAN: All
right, let's make
this something more exciting.
DarkComf exclamation point.
PHIL QUITSLUND: [LAUGHS]
JACOB RICHMAN: And now you'll
see everything updated.
I just did a hot reload.
The inspector understands
hot reload as well,
so our property values
changed there as well.
And now we've got
our longer title.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Right, cool.
So I kind of know
where this is going.
I'm curious, what happens
when you toggle the--
so there's a nice
button at the top that
allows us to toggle
our emulator mode,
so we can get a
whiff of what this
would look like an Android.
We're currently looking at
this in the iOS simulator.
JACOB RICHMAN: All right,
so let me toggle it.
And we got a little
bit of a problem.
That's not the most elegant
looking UI at this point.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Right, so
what so what's going on
is that the text there's
something about the text right
it's sort of spilling
off the screen.
So I'm going to guess there's
something about the text.
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah, so
let's get a look at the text.
And now here, because
we're starting
to ask text questions about
how this is rendering,
we'll want to switch
over to the render tree.
And just like you saw the
widgets in the source code
are tightly linked, the render
tree and the widget tree
are tightly linked.
So if I just click on
the Render Tree tab here,
now I see the render
tree information
about exactly the same widget.
So here I can see
how the text setup.
And if I even go
to the children,
I can see the font size.
Now let me just
toggle back and forth
to see if that
information changed.
OK, it didn't.
So the font size is the
same on iOS or Android.
That's not the issue.
And we can go back
up the paragraph,
and notice that here,
the size of the widget
didn't change either.
So that's not the problem.
We can see that we're
on the right track.
If you look at the parent data
property, that did change.
But in a way, that's not
immediately clear to me why.
So let's go look
up the widget tree
to see what might have
caused that parent data
property to change.
If we go up, go to
the align property,
you'll notice that
on one platform,
align is bottom center.
Well if we go to Android,
alignment's now bottom left.
So you'll see the property
value changing right there.
So that's suggesting maybe
this was a intentional design
decision where on iOS,
it's centered, on Android,
it's aligned on the left.
But it still doesn't explain
why it's going off the screen.
Maybe that window's the
wrong size or something,
I don't know yet.
So let's keep going up.
Now we get to the padding.
And now you can
see on the padding,
the padding is zero
pixels on one platform,
and 72 pixels on the other.
So that's where the problem was.
The padding widget
is pushing the text
off the edge on Android.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Right.
So from this, it feels like
this is a deliberate design
decision.
So on the Android side, we're
using a a default left inset,
whereas on iOS, we're centering.
Can you maybe show us
where this is being set,
and maybe we can come up
with a clever way to work.
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah.
And so when I first
had this issue,
I actually didn't
have any idea myself
why this was really happening.
I could guess from poking
around that it was a platform
difference, but I didn't know.
But now that we can
jump to source locations
for where your widgets
are created, it's obvious.
Let's jump to where this align
widget was actually created.
Even for the platform widgets,
you can still jump to source.
And now I'm in the flexible
space bar widget, just the one
you saw up here.
Here's where, within that
widget, the alignment was set.
And now I can just go follow
it back through the Dart code,
just jumping to definition.
Let me get back there, I just--
I usually use a slightly
smaller font size.
It makes it a little bit easier.
PHIL QUITSLUND:
[LAUGHS] You think?
JACOB RICHMAN: All right.
So now here we are.
We're still in the
flexible space bar class.
And here is exactly
where that code
is that says it should
be centered on iOS,
but not centered on Android.
And so it's great.
I don't have to look at some
C++ code and the platform
implementation details.
It's right here
in this Dart code.
And if I keep looking,
oh look, this widget
has a property that lets
me override the default
behavior if I want to.
PHIL QUITSLUND: All right.
So I'm going to
guess that maybe when
we're setting up our
flexible space bar,
we can maybe pass this value in.
Maybe we can take
a look and see.
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah,
so let's do that.
And once again, I'm
just going to navigate
using the inspector,
because I don't
want to try to remember where
all these source files are.
If I click on that widget, I
see exactly where I created it.
And I just need to add an extra
property to center the title.
And now iOS and Android,
it's centered on both,
and we're all set.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Great, great.
[APPLAUSE]
So it's worth pointing
out in practice,
it may not be the
right solution.
But I think it's
perfectly good for a demo.
So now let's let's move on.
The next thing we're
going to look at
is an actual layout puzzle
that we've presented to users,
and has turned out to be kind of
tricky to resolve in practice.
And our hypothesis
is that the inspector
is going to help us with it.
So here we have a
little demo app.
And the puzzle is
that you'll notice
that the text, the address
text, is really just spanning
half the card.
And what we'd like is for it
to extend to the entire width.
So the puzzle was to
figure out how to do that.
And it turns out,
as we found, it's
harder than you might think.
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah.
A lot of people actually
take a lot of time
to solve this for
the first time.
Let's go ahead and select this
widget with the inspector just
to get to the right
code where it's defined.
And you can see, this
UI's pretty simple.
It's a card with a column,
and text inside it.
And over in the tree
here, here is the column.
And it's got text inside it.
Now let's understand why
this column's the size it is.
Once again, we'll go
with the render tree
to get information about exactly
what the rendered sizes are.
And here, we'll say,
yeah, on the render tree,
the width is only
191 pixels, which
is less than the 300 something
pixels that we're expecting.
But if we look at
the constraints that
were propagated into
this render object,
the constraint
said the widget was
allowed to be 360 pixels wide.
So that's good news.
That means we can probably solve
this problem pretty locally.
The problem isn't
somewhere further
up the tree, where we constrain
the size to be too small.
So given that, let's go
back to the widget, itself,
and see if any of
these properties
tell us what's going on.
So the first property
is the direction.
That's actually
just because this
is a column, and not a row.
If it was a row, you'd see
the direction is horizontal.
So then the main axis
properties, those
are about the vertical axis.
So we don't care about those.
We're happy with
the vertical space.
Very next one is
cross axis alignment.
Now you'll notice, if I
mouseover the property,
I can see what all the
other allowed values are.
And looking at
this list, stretch
looks like what we
want, because we
want to stretch out the
column to fit the whole space.
So let's go ahead and add that.
Right now, the UI updates.
And there is a
correct column size.
Everything is the way we'd want.
You can take a look at it.
So we're all done.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Great.
[APPLAUSE]
So this is great.
So the inspector seems like a
tenable way to explore layouts.
We're hoping that this
makes solving problems
like this a lot easier
for folks in the future.
But what about some of the
more advanced Flutter UI bits?
If we go back to that
main landing page,
there are a few animations.
Can you-- Yeah, exactly.
I wonder--
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah, so
this looks pretty slick.
But I have no idea how I do
that in my own application.
So let's poke
around a little bit,
and see if we can understand
what the framework's doing.
So once again, I'll go ahead
and just select that widget.
All right.
And now, we'll keep going up
the tree a little bit further.
Notice there's a transform
that's applying to the widget.
And I suspect the
transform's probably
what's changing the size.
But if I look at that
widget tree, I can't tell.
So let me switch back
over to the render tree.
And now, I can see information
on exactly how that transform
is currently configured.
Right now, it's scaling
the text by 1.5 times.
And to see how this
animation's going along,
and see as I change the
animation, that scale transform
matrix is changing.
So now I know exactly how
this affect's being achieved.
It's being achieved
with a transform.
And there's how the
transform's changing
as I manipulate the app.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Great.
And then it's worth pointing
out that you can navigate
to the source, and then
we can find the snippet
where this was created.
And we can just
use that ourselves.
JACOB RICHMAN: Right.
So even though this
transform's being
defined in a library
in the framework,
we can jump to definition.
Now we can see
exactly where they're
passing in a scale transform.
And if we just jump to the
definition right there,
there's where it's creating
a matrix with the scale
value, which is tweening
between 1.5 and one,
based on this value here.
So now I get a feel for exactly
how the system is doing it.
And this is just inside--
it's a build method, So I
could feel pretty confident.
I could make this same effect
work in my build method.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Cool.
So that's a pretty
simple transform,
but I know there are some more
complicated animations going
on.
Maybe we can take a look at
a few of those, just to--
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah. let's
take a look at a couple more.
There's a funny
animation demo here
that has some more advanced
transformations happening.
So let's go see if this aspect
would also help for those.
Go ahead and select the widget.
And once again,
I suspect there's
some transform going on here.
So just expand the
tree a little bit.
I got to the transform.
Go over the render tree.
Now I'll switch modes again,
so I can manipulate the app.
Now you can see the
transform matrix changing
as the animation occurs.
And of course, unless
you're a lot better
than I am at matrix
math, you probably
don't really know what that's
doing from that code there.
But let's look at
the other property
that's being animated here.
The opacity's actually changing
as this animation occurs.
And now this is something
that I could actually
imagine I'd find useful,
tweaking this UI effect.
So you want to see how
faded the widget gets right
when it's about to go off
the edge of the screen.
So now I can see that it's faded
to about 0.6 at that point.
So that might be helpful for me.
But so let's look
at another case
where the widget
inspectors won't currently
show you what's going
on in the animation,
but at least they'll
tell you what's
not happening in the animation
so you can know what to do.
In this Pesto app, there's a
slick transition between pages
here where it looks like
this image is just moving up
the top of the screen.
So we can find out if
that's really happening
by using the inspector.
Let me go ahead and
select the image.
And now I'll go ahead and
trigger the animation.
And the section disappeared.
But as we saw before,
the inspection's
pretty good at sticking
to the render object
if the render object's
just animating.
So this means something
more complicated's going on.
And you could go
find out what that
is by jumping to the
definition of the Hero class
that's responsible for
performing this animation.
And the excellent
documentation will
tell you how this
Hero class is actually
making it look like
it's moving the image,
but is really creating a
new image at the location
of the previous image, and
then moving that image over
to the location it needs
to be for the final page,
so that that final image you
see is part of the final page,
instead of part of
the previous page.
PHIL QUITSLUND: All right.
Great So I think that
ends the demo part here.
And to sum up, we've
done a few things.
So one thing is
that I hope you've
seen that the inspector lets
you navigate these neighborhoods
of interest in the widget tree.
We showed you that great,
big, scary nested tree.
But you're not really
confronted by that,
because this
bidirectional mapping
is ensuring that your
focused only in the area
that you're interested in.
We've shown that you can do
a little bit of spelunking,
and hopefully solve some
layout related issues.
But you can also
learn quite a bit more
about some of the more
advanced features in flutter,
like animations.
Can you bring us back
to the main slides?
So it's worth
emphasizing that most
of what Jacob showed you
is available for download
today, with one caveat.
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah.
That mapping between your source
code and the widget tree, that
requires Kernel
Transformers that
are only available with new
common frontend in Dart 2.
So you'll have to wait until
Flutter runs with Dart 2
to use those.
You can try it with
a flag [INAUDIBLE],,
but it's not ready
for general use.
PHIL QUITSLUND: And we also, on
deck, have quite a few features
that we'll be rolling
out pretty soon here.
Yeah, this is just the minimum
we think will be useful.
We're going to be
working hard now
on letting you tweak
some widget properties
right inside the inspector,
instead of going to your source
code.
It'll let you filter
the tree by category.
So if you're only interested
in layout, you can filter it
so you only see widgets that are
actually affecting your layout.
It's going to make the trees
a bit smaller for those cases.
And then we also want to
visualize some layout related
properties like padding.
You can think of the box
model you're probably
familiar with on the web.
We want to just
show that visually,
instead of as a string of text.
And then coming soon, we'll
provide support and other IDs
as well.
This currently works in
IntelliJ and Android studio.
PHIL QUITSLUND: Great.
So if you want to learn
more, the GitHub project page
is up there.
We have an issue tracker.
Please feel free to
give us feedback there.
Flutter IO is a great place
to learn more about Flutter.
And the Flutter
developer community
is really great,
and really engaged.
So be sure to go to
Gitter or Stack Overflow
if you want to engage with them.
And by all means,
come talk to us.
We'll be around for the
next couple of days.
I don't know if we're going
to do an unconference or not,
but we'll be around
in the courtyard
and happy to talk about the
inspector and all things
Flutter and Dart.
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah. so come
to our unconference section.
You can play with this demo,
and see how it works for you.
PHIL QUITSLUND: All
right, thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
JACOB RICHMAN: Thank you.